hello everybody
today we're going to try to do some
coding challenges um i'm going to do a
quick introduction first
my name is tom
and i work for free code camp and i
created the relational database courses
that are now available on
freecodecamp.org
and i will share a link in the
description
to those if you want to try them out
with me here is sean you want to
introduce yourself sean
yeah sure hello code breakers
my name is sean i
also work for free code camp and i
created the rustic raptor course as well
as the euler rust project
whoops
yeah
it's there there he is
okay so what are we what are we gonna do
today sean
so today
we have been invited by brooke by tech
domains to
do their break the code
this is the second time break the code
has come out the first time was in 2020
and it was hugely popular so
today tom and i are going to be going
through
and doing a let's play of break the code
2.
yeah i haven't uh i haven't checked it
out at all other than this first screen
um
yes i don't really know what it's all
about but uh looks like there's some
signing to get playing rules and prizes
let's uh
check out some rules basically there's
like a timeline it says there's eight
days left which would make it finish on
april 15th i think
um
so if you're able to get it done by
april 15th
you can win some of these prizes instead
is that how it works
yes that sounds about right so
they started
on april 1st and they opened these
drives sequentially
and each drive contains missions that
you do
and
we're going to find out what those
missions are for
drives one and two but currently drive
three is open which you can complete and
when the price is associated with that
drive
so it's like there's some pretty
nice prizes here
good old ps1
and a ps5 so yeah we're gonna try and
finish these first two drives today i
think and then um
yeah if you finish drive one you can
potentially win a ps5
or some other things
drive two the grand prize is a macbook
pro
and drive three
um
five thousand dollars worth of ethereum
what's that right
well that's what it looks like yeah
it's quite impressive
and these are surprises yeah i don't
know what this is code breakers layer
custom gaming rig and monitor okay and
share oh that's what this is right here
all right well
um
i suppose if you are watching this
post
when the prize and the competition has
ended um you can
still welcome to watch and get the
entertainment value from tom trying to
go through this oh
i'm gonna find a way to drag you into
this don't worry about it
i think we're going to try and treat
this as a pure dev session
supposedly the missions are quite a bit
like um
i suppose coding challenges so
let's find out
all right well i started this up and it
says uh i have a new email from
carehq
and it's dated december 99.
it looks like it's some
recruiter is looking to hire me
um suppose out lock express
so yeah this is kind of cool we got like
a windows 95 or 98 theme going on
yeah i believe it's 98.
no this is awesome
click on click on clippy there
let's see
i got the job at here okay
yes i uh
read the first sentence of that email
anyway
i'm clicking on
clippy and not much is happening oh
something happened
a bunch of stuff showed up don't click
me okay
that's tempting isn't it
it sure is
um
i guess
we'll just
close the email
and
play around a little bit we got log off
shut down classic
i'll see what programs they say
not pad
code editor isn't wasn't notepad the
code editor
back on 98.
ipad was just everything
everything text
now we have easter eggs left behind
well i can't type
all right so i'm assuming this is maybe
something we're going to be using
um i imagine we'll try and use a lot of
it
mine labor
this is this is like riding a bike here
bringing back good memories
yeah
did you ever play minesweeper
oh yeah quite a lot
i didn't spend much time on
uh windows 98 but
i had windows xp for about
10 years until windows 10 came out and
then upgraded from xp to windows 10.
so it was quite the jump
yeah
um
well we know we're supposed to go
through the drives so
i think we should just start as drive
one
oh i'm hearing
noises i don't know if if that's coming
through or not um
i can't hear any
revamp it's a sealed uh yeah napster
when amp and napster
um
this is classic
what we got here
drive one i guess we'll click on this
okay code breaker tom
even though you're still considered
recently recruited code breaker carol b
assigning you a mission of top level
importance
three of our essential satellites have
been systematically disconnected during
recent sync attempts okay so we've got
some
satellites that are disconnected sounds
like a problem
our technicians have had a hard time
identifying pattern but they have
uncovered traces of a virus
linked to the anarchist organization
dot gang
okay our intel has uncovered four areas
of investigation
that we believe could have clues
to regain control
we need you to assess the situation and
attempt to access the damaged systems
at the same time keep an eye out for dot
gang's methods that we can exploit down
the line okay oh boy maybe that's
take some notes or something
and drive on you'll find all the leads
that we have collected in our
investigations analyze each one and try
to find the relevant connections
report everything you find in hq
as with all covert assignments unless
specifically authorized by hq take no
action all right
sean
so
what are you thinking
i'm thinking
we're investigating
we're investigating their satellites
going down and we need to just report
everything we find
including
potentially if we find something useful
that this
anarchist organization has done
then we need to
keep it in our
repertoire of tricks to potentially use
against them
okay
[Music]
so maybe i should use that notepad well
let's just uh explore i guess and if we
come across
information maybe we'll take a note um
drive one
okay
g drive
c drive look at that
a giant bunny was spotted leaving
go dot tech oh slash okay maybe open the
web explorer
g chords
yeah it's also useful
yeah now go where they
where clippy told you to go
oh geez i just said it
yeah
it was something that tech slash
oh is and i hit the back button browser
took
browser hotkeys took over
drive one box of chocolates now
and i go to one ladder
and go to that website
can't copy
there we go
awesome
because obviously nada are involved with
getting the
satellites up in there so
they must be
how did you put that one together that
just went right over my head
no no no okay okay
moonwalking or moon driving
got an article here
security update that sounds potentially
useful um
and he had an unscheduled stop on a
malfunctioning seat belt
i don't know how much of this
information is
useful nada clearly needs a librarian
that's another hint we need to hear
[Music]
okay there's a lot of information here
um
that's frequently asked questions
uh no this is clickable
no okay
none of this is clickable
1919 the internet's friendly reminder
that life is slipping away click the
lifespan
none of these are clickable but
that sounds
scary
i wonder if it's a white y2k thing
probably
that's probably what the ads look like
on
on the internet 99
the death the giant internet death is
coming y2k
so they they recently needed to change
their passwords
and
currently there are three letter
passwords so that's something we can
guess
[Music]
i called jackson moon walked on the moon
would we call it a
moonwalk
would we talk
what are you reading
you didn't see the note from cliffy
no what did it say
michael jackson moonwalk on the moon
would we call it a moon moonwalk
yes
yes you would
[Music]
so really probably should just read all
this huh
no i wouldn't i think
not that much if we get it just of it we
can just move on and if we need to come
back to it we will
i think there's probably weird hints in
there like when it talks about
malfunctioning seat belts and
you know morium of charles pete and the
fact that all passwords are currently
three letters
yes please do not use the same three
letters three times
that sounds like a hint
that's what clippy said
no right there on the
uh
yeah
okay
new so the new format is nine
and the current
three letters will be phased out
yeah this is
[Music]
any idea where we're going with it
so the other thing
um
there's these three buttons resolve is
where we
go when we think we have the answer
right i've already forgot
yeah
though but i don't have any answers
has used national's old account right
okay so they use the three letter
password
to erase all the logs
and the first part of their password is
cbc
first the first part of their new
password so is that the new
they use an astronaut's old account so
the astronaut's new account starts with
cpc
uh you know what
the password is definitely cpc cpc cpc
why
because it says ps do not use the same
three letters three times
wouldn't that mean it couldn't be that
please do not use the same three letters
three times do not or
well i don't know if i'm told that with
my password i'm definitely going to do
it
so you're saying because they said not
to do it that that's what you would do
yeah
that sounds about right in my mind well
let's just try it huh
are we allowed to get the answer wrong
i don't know
but it looks like that's the format
wrong answer okay maybe we should just
build a brute force
script to try and
well what if we know
what if we do permutations of that cpc
so we do cpc ccp pcc
i think the whole answer
because
because that's just guessing
yes
what's your idea
um keep exploring until we find
well you got that wrong anyway what
we're supposed to find um there's a lot
of
permutations there i think um
okay see would help hint hint hint no we
don't want his
hints
we probably need them but yeah
we can set ourselves a time limit and if
we don't get there we'll just oh there
we go look in the world of charles pete
conrad that's why it's cpc
charles p conrad oh that sounds
interesting
nice eyes on that one
a former navy test pilot
right there cpc died
at the hospital in
fuji
my thought here was that in this little
snippet on the left
we have
three words that are capitalized and
then it says that
i wanted to just kind of see if i could
see anything else here's something jbi
yeah i think that's probably also
important james benson irwin so we got
two names and two
capitalized
abbreviations is there there's seatbelt
rock no
seatbelt rock
there's something about these astronauts
but it's six feet under okay there's
gotta be another astronaut name well
that's because of the charles p conrad
who died
okay so they're making jokes about
somebody's
is that what's happening i think the
theme here the theme here is death
because we have the death clock right we
have white okay
and we have these astronauts so that's
definitely something
so
well i think one one dead astronaut are
these ones dead
no
okay
what what were you gonna say
well
i think
do you think there's anything in that
that hint that clippy gave of
no who knew astronauts needed to be so
first look at look at those ads
yes
maybe i'm thinking was abs capitalized
i can't remember
well i think you can always try this
there's no harm in doing that so
so we got c p c dash j b i
i slash abs
what if it's abs
jbi
well we didn't find them in that order
so it can't be that hard
all right
oh wait
oh snap he got it
awesome man we're good at this
excellent extraction
code breaker now that we have the full
password we can take back control of the
hacked account
so doc gang won't be able to use it on
our satellites
i'm going to record that password so the
cpc
abs
and
no i don't have
no i'm pretty sure twitter didn't exist
back then
yeah that's a good point
um
i'm not alone
on this um
oh i get it now i see there's there's
four things for drive one that we all
have to finish
things to share with friends what was it
i saw pizza but
pizza and drinks i think
so where did our
our
three hints there two of them were in
that article and one came from clippy
right
i think they all came from libby because
tippy talked about the dead astronaut
who was cbc
that we talked about the
astronaut with the six-pack
[Music]
there's no way to get the abs one
without
clippy and the other two were in that
article
i don't think there's anything saying
that we have to find all of the hints on
the one page
yeah
but things to share with your friends
clearly songs is something you're
sharing 141 songs
so
maybe this is another thing of three and
141 is the first
this looks very
copyright
problematic
what are they
piracy that's what they called it right
yeah you're not supposed to do this you
haven't even looked at the brief of this
yet
okay okay brief mission
part
1b
napster
we intercepted communication
that revealed
dot gang's plan to inject a virus into
napster downloads neither be a virus
here
so i heard of this song
have you heard of this software it's
absurd it plays to share compressed
music files through the internet
there's no way the public would be
interested in something like this but we
need to get ahead of it so begin your
next mission do whatever you can to
identify the virus
okay so potentially one or more of these
files are viruses and let's see mission
name napster drive one mission two
answer okay
so we have two hints so far
the one is things to share with friends
we saw pizza i'm thinking songs is the
other
and then
something about looking at the songs so
many typos
if you know you're going to love or hate
the song from the very first word
well
i see a typo here
okay
a lot of viruses do have typos in them
here's a typo so i see two tables
are we looking for the letters that are
missing
like h and a
it's a type of oh maybe b
you're nobody's supposed to be here so
that'd be an h
and
have you ever a
a so aj
hard knock life ghetto anthem livin la
vida loca
i think that's probably the virus right
there
and that's just the movies
jumper p so h-a-p
um
yeah
yeah yeah
lenny kravitz maybe there's typos
elsewhere
fly away
let me see elliot tripping is there
another p missing there
it seems like there might supposed to be
two pieces here but i'm not sure
difficult to say yeah
nikki
it's not right but it's okay
there's a comma missing
give it to you oh there's one why
i guess i've always felt the word happy
i don't think that's a coincidence
so
shall we try it
happy yeah
h-a-p-p-y
happy
gilmore
um
let's see oh we've got more people here
or something
so this was
music kid is that me
is that us
and gang oh
oh there they are
that's the that's the
the hackers or whatever
all right let's see this one all these
but goodies robbie
robertson
up on [ __ ] creek
moses
ellison mosey allison parchman farm
willie nelson georgia on my mind
that's race to play i don't see any
typos
now
this one here looks like there might be
a typo because
has a capital d
in a lower case s
interesting
the one above also has a capital t
though so maybe the lowercase s is more
important
yeah like this one has on capitalize
so everything is capitalized it looks
like except for
test here happy
[Music]
this one's cut off
can i see the rest
i don't know if i could
okay well that's the only thing that i
see
um
frequencies times length
someone
yeah i was looking at the length to try
and see if something seemed strange
555
that seems fake
um
you could go online and look up the
length of the songs that they actually
are to see if they match
we do have the web explorer
we do
i don't think we really have access to
the internet though
i think my camera is a little off here
you know are you going to level hate a
song from the very first word
how do you tell if you're going to love
or hate a song from the very
maybe try happy together
are we looking for one song or multiple
songs
well i think like this first area
we put together the word happy from the
missing typos so i
don't know i think we just need like one
word or one
group of words so yeah
and all the length of those songs is
zero
happy together
napster for movies
so
high school musical cast we got some
artists and then we're all in this
together get together
we all stand together together
better together get yourself together
happy together
um
well this one has
a longer dash
than the rest of them
happy dash together
so yes you're right the length is all
zero
that could be a potential
clue
file size is zero so these are all
clueless man all these but goodies music
kid
can i click on anything else
upgrade your billboard magazine
subscription
no i don't want any help
well
suppose something else
i don't know can you go to the web
explorer and
go to go go.text reddit or something
slash reddit
we go and get help from the community i
suppose
was it this course or discord
i don't know
it's a word
uh now clip he's just giving us bad hits
uh clippy's getting frustrated with us
we are too slow um
okay
i think all the clues are in here though
somewhere
well so far we're certain of happy entry
pretty sure yeah
there's something about happy
there's something special about together
there
yeah
and the length
of the songs
and so far clippy has said
that something about missing a beat i
didn't catch that one
um
we looked at the songs for the typos
and things to share okay 4 million songs
150 000 users
i twitter get go
so you have 141 songs is that special
i thought it said 140 when we first
started
yeah
okay
um
so
i i don't know
were you going somewhere with that
well i'm trying to think i'll be coming
up with maybe
another three
um
three set of three password
so i listed these
i'm thinking it's just
maybe three words you know one word
happy i think is the word for this page
and then we've got these other two pages
i don't know if we need to find a word
in each one or
a word
combined
go back to the brief let's see if
there's a hint there
we intercepted communication
that revealed.gang's plan to inject the
virus into napster downloads have you
heard of this software it's absurd a
place to share compressed music files
through the internet
there's no way the public would be
interested in something like this
clearly
but we need to get ahead of it so begin
your next mission and do whatever you
can to identify the virus happy so one
one of the files is going to be the
virus
i'm not sure if it's just one file but
yeah you might be right but you would
think
like happy together would be it what if
you type in that whole thing the turtles
happytogether.mp3
there you go
now you're thinking
turtles happy
together
mp3
no
did i misspell something
try without the mp3
i just feel like we're missing something
because there's still
typos here like there's this dash and
something on this page let's pretend
that's a hint you know what would be
great napster for movies
any of these movies
quite
possibly
high school musical that's a movie kind
of
yeah all in this together get you the
real statues what is the turtles
you know this this one this one is not
capitalized either this i
everything else is capitalized almost
and the and
yeah but those aren't supposed to be
capitalized if this was written
correctly but there are all capitalized
everywhere else here in the
i mean it's supposed to be capitalized
when it's a song pick songs and bring
them together into a brand new playlist
that's what we're doing
we can't do anything with these
no no but we're clearly trying to
take
a collection of all of these songs and
make a brand new playlist
so
i think we just need
a small a few few word answer is what we
need i don't know what you mean by make
a playlist
well
there's something in all three of those
that would make
a playlist
write down these these uncapitalized
letters s
i
i
um
and then there's this weird dash okay
will we say now we need to make a
playlist somehow i don't know
well try that try happy sia
sure
could be
capitalized
i wouldn't put a space yeah yeah see ya
is that a song
see ya as an artist
well then you should say sia happy yeah
um
come on fingers crossed
kept less
i wonder how specific it's gonna be
um
see ya
mp3
do you know any of her songs by chance
no
nothing's coming to mind
um
[Music]
that sounds like that's on the right
track to be honest i don't know see ya
happy together
this whole page has the word together in
it
yeah
kind of strange
okay well let's keep that in our mind so
we have happy and together and go to
please but goodies
what's special about this one because we
haven't really seen anything other than
the
missing capital wise
from the very first word i assume that's
happy
maybe it's not
love or hate
so
that whole page is capitalized weird too
hey here's another typo there's a colon
right there
interesting
what did that last thing say
upgrade
to the new millennium
to yeah
fix the virus so if i change my time
break the code to prizes catalog
yes
i think go to start and look for
the way to change the data
display
[Music]
so there's a show clock
thing right
in settings
yeah but just show clock it wasn't
well click show hidden files and folders
that might be useful for later
there we go
that looks interesting
that's potentially helpful later on or
something
select screen saver
okay
we'll go to this one anyway because
um
okay
so
i don't see a way to change that i
clicked on this i can't change anything
um
don't click me
mine leaper terminal my computer
what's in the readme
it's december 31st 1999 the cusp of the
new millennium
the electricity in the air makes this
day feel like a once-in-a-lifetime event
upcoming parties will be the stuff of
legend but while people plan their new
year celebrations in the real world an
unseen struggle is raging far from view
hidden away behind internet protocols
and dial-up modems
computers are facing their greatest
threat since
since the apple newton a new destructive
virus disrupting digital services
and quickly spreading the infection to
the far reaches of the virtual world but
who's behind it
that's what you code breaker need to
figure out
along the way you'll meet other code
breakers not unlike yourself
okay i don't think we need to keep
reading this
file edit help
help about the game surprises if you're
stuck
this game isn't for the faint-hearted
all right we can't give up on this sean
so if you're here don't fret you're not
alone of course you need a little nudge
in the right direction here a few things
you can try to recruit a friend to
unlock hints
more code breakers you recruit the more
hints you unlock
some call it sneaky we call it a sure
shot way to share the awesomeness
so i guess if i were to like maybe share
this with you
i would get a better hint
refresh current lists
well no let's keep back with the hints
we've just read
okay
so
we got this misspelled one we know it's
happy the oldies but goodies we know
it's upgrade version
and the clueless man
it's together so maybe you do need to
share it
for something
you have to do something together
um
so what does that mean go on twitter
and discord or something and share it
with you
i'm not sure i don't know why it keeps
saying the four million the songs 150
000 users
your recruitment link
look at that
can i paste it
why don't you try visiting this
yeah i can try
let me send it to you
that is what we're supposed to find i
think it said something about this six
degrees thing i forgot what it was
share your recruitment link get the most
recruits and get awarded hint points and
an ipad air
i'll be
that sounds worth it
remember recruiting existing code
breakers does not count
points are only awarded after the
referred person completes the signup
processor
recruitment points are reset for every
drive
the table below updates every four hours
i think this is it we have to
i have to have a recruit to do this
maybe
but there was still that the hint about
the time
said upgrade to the new millennium it's
10 p.m right now maybe we just need to
wait two hours
that has been ticking up slowly so
there is the chance
we could add your screen to the video
maybe that just over complicates it what
do you see do you see exactly what i see
yeah no nothing looks different
um
wall street journal the mission is
accessible only by via web explorer
revamp
would you like a walkthrough boxer this
is classic
treespin mirror um
i am just going to
i did not think i'm just gonna finish
this one quick
was it ct dash abs
share with your friends maybe i'm
supposed to share it
i'm not logged in
you can write that down as a note maybe
share together
but you're here now
i don't see your name here refresh okay
there you go
okay
let me solve a mission
do you want to um
just maybe talk about what you're
you're doing or potentially we should
share
things to share with your friends
secrets pizza and your six degrees link
there you go
secrets pizza six degrees
that's what's that was the hint
that we missed
we got the pizza in the drinks right
away but it just too fast
and then
it took us a half an hour to get to the
next step um
i'm just completing that first mission
yeah i already went back and did that
too
and i can share it
you want to share it
i don't i just don't feel like that's
not gonna do anything but i maybe
drive one blocks of chocolate
c drive
files games
now it said upgrade to the new
millennium so
go to the terminal
go to the terminal and upgrade
the time change the time
how do i change the time from the
terminal
there's also a hello
the hints
yeah
there are hence no for the gray matter
four six clippy you're too fast i can't
read
dude hello
typing headlight
hello
brilliant okay say ping
that thing my valid parameter is what
would be my address i mean we know about
one like not at that tech
nothing
okay
giant bunny was spotted leaving code
dot
take
hmm
where's my history
well i gotta look at the cheat codes
we need to upgrade the version of
something
is it napster we need to upgrade
pain time average
[Music]
um
[Music]
i think we just need to explore stuff
i it said upgrade the
upgrade to the new millennium upgrade
the virus to the new millennium
[Music]
so the virus would be
create the file
upgrade the system time upgrade the
napster
leave behind 19.99 welcome 2000 delays
students
upgrade your billboard magazine
subscription today
that sounds promising
yeah that does actually
right in front of your face the whole
time billboard
sorry i feel like that's it in the
terminal
what install billboard
[Music]
so clippy
i don't know about that
great
leave behind anyone can you see that
yeah okay yeah
upgrade your subscription
online alessandro
that's probably just a current version
1999.
weird
um
files
dude let's just look at all these
this
bill gates
nothing
oh here's the mp3 file
interesting
in the c drive
files blue one love i wonder if that's
in the
interesting thing
it's a horse
did you hear that yeah
okay
download
i suppose we'll download it i don't know
what that's gonna do
sounds like a horse again
okay so
blue one love
let's look at this one we got a bear and
some birds
if you go to the cheat codes
in the notepad
where was that
right here
yeah it has the link to the repository
and then in the terminal you can clone
the repository
you just said that i take it
oh
not connect to github please try again i
did not have any success
did you do it no i didn't did it work
for you why don't you give it a try and
tell me if it works
time net address port install
plugin
install
billboard
oh
napster
okay
create your billboard magazine
subscription today that's definitely the
clue
i just don't know how to do it
[Music]
take screenshot share
i'm just manually going to the reaper
okay
oh you know why
it's not a link to a repo that's just a
link to
someone's profile
to the breakthrough profile
and there's a repo in that profile
called neo
which is an advanced free and universal
game trainer plugin
for the operating system
that was in the cheat codes
yeah it codes all right let's check it
out
just go to the first link there
um
the 98.
there it is
plugin
install
run hack x github repo
all right let's try this
terminal
bunny was spotted leaving go.tech slash
ig easter eggs were left behind
install run and okay we call in the
repository
here we go
we got run hack x installed your run
program has been upgraded
to run hack x you can now use it to
execute cheat codes by simply going to
start
high x
and
run run hacks
let's probably run a hacks
close enough
um
well i mean use the code hacker man
that's 100 points
all right clippy i'm going to put she
over here
that's all we want to do this
hacker man
that's achieved but
it must mean something
uh yeah yeah what else to try
so
there's the hint of
obviously we have
we've decoded the first one right we got
happy
the second one as well
we got upgrade version
and then the third one helps with how to
write the answer
together
so
happy upgrade version
have we tried
that i haven't tried much
yeah well that's
470
upgrade
version
happy
together maybe maybe we both need to
enter it in the box at the same time
together
yeah
i tried it without any spaces and it
didn't work
happy
upgrade version together
the third one tells you how to enter it
together
yes you are here
i'm happy
20.00
[Music]
it's it says
[Music]
you're getting that off discord or
reddit or something that the third thing
tells us how to do it how to how to
enter
yeah
the third one helps with how to write
the answer
so
we have happy
upgrade
version
[Music]
zero
current version
i don't know if you get the same thing
but if you get an answer wrong it makes
a funny noise sometimes
up upgrade
version
so
that's nothing i got nothing
it says
devtools
um
happy
upgrade version
together
and
19.99 or 20.
0 0
i was going to say that maybe we should
i don't know give it a little more time
and see if we can just
look up the answer give it up
we're on the second thing and we can't
figure it out
some hard stuff
oh
i keep looking at i
leave behind
your billboard 19.99
i don't know
all these but goodies
get in there
[Music]
replace
upgrade version with the upgraded
version
you looked it up
no
okay
so
put in your answer
2
happy
really is that what it is
well i put it without the space but yeah
wow
it was all there just
wow
that um
yeah that's
right there
it's sad when you have it but
happy upgrade version
together
i wonder if it would have failed if you
weren't in in there with me
well i got through so i don't think so